are you ready hon Smith hey no I think
he's ready all right I'm Becca I think
Chris Hemsworth is pretty much ready for
anything is it he ha ha and he's
completely surrounded by girl power so
he's got that in the Huntsman winters
war we're talking Charlize Theron Emily
Blunt and Jessica Chastain listen being
on that set was like being transported
in some kind of magical land big stars
massive sets incredible costumes
I made the trek to Surrey England to
take it all in is it like the ultimate
dress-up
oh yeah I've never done anything like
this have you mm-hmm
I mean in my spare time not for films
but at home of course oh yeah
blue gown black leather evil queen
Charlize where several Colleen Atwood
costumes in this action-packed prequel
her cape is hand-painted gold made of
real feathers and weighs more than 50
pounds Emily's dress was 80 pounds all
the Stars had numerous wardrobe changes
except for this guy how's it working
with those three ladies it's there's a
lot of antigen around you it's like
having three sisters is it yeah yeah I
get bullied a lot do you yeah they'll
say I believe that much is not true
girls Chris would like to think that
we're always talking about him but um no
we do we do give me a hard time they're
laughing and you feel like the odd man
out with me oh the women are the ones
with most of the power here Charlize can
cast spells Emily her sister can turn
things to ice and Jessica who plays
Chris's wife holds her own in fight
scenes nice sure it looks like you're a
badass I get to fight Chris a little bit
which was fun
I'd say where I have like almost 5
inches snuck inside of my shoes because
he's just obnoxiously tall I'll share
makeup is that all you know I am so
white in real life the I do spray tan
every week so I do a spray tan to kind
of give me like rugged look in fact no
one even seems to care that Kristen was
named sexiest man alive back in 2014 I
wasn't even aware though Liz he is he's
the sexiest man alive I didn't hear that
I thought that was George Clooney yeah
might have been a while back
yes that's gonna come back to bite you
oh my god it's tight just vapid bity is
it oh I'm stronger than all of you shall
we find out
now behind me is the place that Emily
Blunt calls home during the movie she is
Freya The Snow Queen one of the coolest
parts of this set are the three thousand
resin icicles all over now they look
like the real deal but actually when you
touch them they feel like jelly I'm
telling everybody here Elsa you're okay
with that I'm not great with it we
should have a frozen on with you and
Elsa that would be really who would win
well even though Emily gets cool points
for kind of being Elsa Charlize is
four-year-old son Jackson thinks mom
wins he came to set today and he was
watching a rehearsal and he turned to my
mom and he just went mama spicy well
Charlize told me that Jackson really
isn't freaked out by her makeup but he
does call his spicy mama the witch and
asked where's her apple
you